I recently stumbled upon a test called HTMA air tissue
mineral analysis. What are your thoughts on this test?
And would you recommend it?
So if it's a here analysis test, you take a clip of your hair.
So I'm discussing it because I don't know what this test is.
So just by the name of it, I'm sure that it's a clip of your hair
and you're setting it in for mineral analysis instead of for heavy metal analysis.
I would say it's not a good test for mineral analysis.
And hair analysis is not the best test for heavy metal analysis, either.
But there isn't a lot of other good tests for heavy metal analysis.
So there is a urine test for heavy metal analysis.
So if you're taking a strong key later, like DMSA, kind of it overabundance
to pull it out of the tissues to dump what you can into the urine.
So then you're measuring it.
And I think that's a very poor test because you can make a person really sick with that test.
So I think hair analysis is the best option that exists for heavy metal testing.
If you want to really assess mineral analysis in your body,
you really have to do an intracellular nutritional test.
I forgot to name that test off the top of my head because I don't ever use that test.
Hair analysis mineral test, I'd say no, do not use that.
It's not going to be accurate at all.
Second part of the question, I've had a Dutch test.
So a Dutch test is a dried urine analysis test for four bones.
And your cheek swab tests.
I'm wondering if this test would offer additional benefits.
I'd say no, don't do that test.
It's not other tests that can offer benefits.
I get out of the courses if I were you and look at what you're trying to analyze.
And the information that you're trying to gain.
And as you go through the courses, something might spark your attention.
Like, oh, my gosh, this, I should do this micotox test because I was exposed to, you know, mold so much in my life.
And maybe that's is kind of a hidden issue.
Well, then, so that's what other reason why I created these courses is for you guys to be able to study on your own to go, wow, this could be a possible solution for myself too.
Get out there. You have free access to all those courses.
You would recommend it.